Good Morning John.
So it's a little shocking to me and like a
lot of other people that a fourteen year old
kid in a NASA shirt brought a clock that he
built to school to show his engineering teacher
and was arrested and taken to a juvenile detention
center.
But then on the other hand, it's not shocking
because Ahmed Mohamed's name is Ahmed Mohamed
and he is Muslim.
And many people in America are afraid of Muslims.
Now I'm not going to make a video here about
how the vast vast vast majority of Muslims,
just like any other broad diverse group of
people, are good people.
Two reasons for that: first, finding these
statistics on the internet that make this
very clear is pretty easy.
Second, making a video defending Muslims would
ignore the actual problem which is the bias
and the fear mongering that creates suspicion
and hatred and those things are our problems.
And our problems we can deal with so much
more easily than trying to deal with other
people's problems, especially when those problems
are imagined.
Now of course, it's not super comfortable
to recognize your own problems and it doesn't
make you feel all good which is why this video
is not gonna go super viral.
But since it is the actual problem, and also
one that we can deal with conceivably since
we are the ones with the problem, that's what
I want to make the video about.
So why do so many Americans, including, I'll
be honest sometimes myself, fall into this
fear trap?
First, because it's just impossible to know
everything about everyone, and though Muslims
have been in America since America existed,
they are a significant minority, less than
1%.
So most Americans simply don't know much about
Muslims or the Islamic faith.
But we do hear about Muslims fairly regularly
on the news, and we hear about the scariest
Muslims in the world.
So if you're expected to have an idea of what
Muslim people are like and this is the only
input you're getting, you're gonna have a
really messed up idea.
It's an easy mistake for a brain to make,
but it is a huge mistake, because we know
nothing!
An example: What percentage of Muslims would
you say live in the Middle East?
80%? 85%?
That's what I would've said before starting
to research this video.
How about 20%? 60% of Muslims live in Asia.
The single country with the largest Muslim
population?
Indonesia.
If we are ignorant of such a basic fact, how
could we consider ourselves qualified to make
sweeping generalizations about a broad and
diverse group of people?
Once these negative ideas are set up in our
brain, they can be easily reinforced in people
who are motivated by fear and outrage.
Those people watch other people on TV who
professionally cultivate outrage and fear
because it's good for ratings, and that fear
then prevents conversations and causes the
majority to isolate Muslims from their broader
communities by doing thing like, for example,
arresting a kid for bringing a clock to class.
So the fear builds on itself until what was
once ignorance and became fear eventually
becomes hatred.
And once you hate someone, they know it.
Muslims in America are certainly not ignorant
of the hatred and the discrimination, but
Muslims in other countries aren't ignorant
of the more extreme American views, either.
In fact, I'm willing to bet that in the same
way that we are mostly just about scary Muslims
on American news, in other countries they
hear mostly about the scariest versions of
Americans.
And if people in other countries are gonna
put us in a little box, which they are bound
to do because no one can know everything about
everyone, what little box do we want to get
put into?
Do we want to be in the "hates Muslims" box,
or do we want to be in the "values religious
freedom and provides opportunities for people
who seek it" box.
I think we should fight that fear.
I think we can fight that fear and the only
way to do it, the only place to do it is up
here.
It's right in here.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.